Hello Freak bitches.
Now you,
but you've also been real open about steroids in which I think is very
commendable because it's one of those things in the world of power lifting the
world of bodybuilding and even in the world of fighting,
it's a dirty,
dark secret that people like to keep to themselves.
But your grandpa can take it.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
I,
I believe in my,
in my opinion,
there should be,
you should pass the physical.
No one has the right to tell you what to do in this world.
One,
when it comes time to die on the one that's got a die so much time for me to
live,
let me lead the life I want to live.
But what do you think in terms of the,
the problem with a lot of people have the problem,
the problem they see with using steroids in sports is it's going to force young
people to use steroids to be able to compete with the people that are using
them.
Hey,
good.
Anyhow.
Yeah.
But if everybody's forced to be cleaned and they don't like what we're doing now
with the UFC,
you were like the Usada,
the,
the people that have stepped in,
Jeff Novitsky running that program,
the guy who caught Lance Armstrong,
well,
actually Lance Armstrong was never caught,
right.
Hey Pat,
He passed 25 tests for seven years in a row and never was tested.
See,
it's not against the rules to take drugs.
It's against the rules and get caught taking drugs.
Um,
that's a fucking loophole.
You've got a good doctor.
You're on the craft,
but not,
not.
So that's why there should be no,
do you know,
uh,
tie should period said make it an even playing field.
Stopped the drug test.
I'd say the same thing and we're not all born was seeing my testosterone.
That's true.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
if I was born today,
I would be in prison.
You're not telling me I teach all these,
you know,
some of those fighters have got way more testosterone.
Did another fighter that's true.
Not born.
Same amount.
So the only thing you could,
why not for,
you know,
train.
You've got a better,
if you've got a better,
uh,
you know you could kick my ass because you do Jujitsu and shit and I don't do
any,
but that don't mean you're tougher than me.
I just mean you had a better coach in me.
So are you cheating me?
That's a good point.
But if two guys do have the same coaches and they do have similar body types,
and one guy's taking steroids,
he's going to have an advantage,
right?
But isn't it pharmaceutical?
What are you looking at your watch TV every five minutes you got a drug
commercial one,
right?
Every year I'll be 69 and let's take all the,
God,
I'm 68 I'll be 600 to almost take all the health medication of 68 year old.
I'd be the only one left on her.
I don't have any ailment.
Common will tell you my problem is they go to the doctor does note that Romy,
there's nothing wrong with me.
I had to beat the crap out of myself physically.
I don't have high blood pressure and cholesterol,
I don't have anything.
And so let's just take all the drugs away.
But all the old 68 year old guys die off as permanent.
Well,
it'd be the only one lip for garlic.
All the old women.
Yeah.
Well for a guy like you who's not competing and Z,
one of the arguments for fighting is that steroids allow you to do more damage
to your opponent.
And that is one of the reasons why,
uh,
steroids should be illegal is because you can train harder,
you have more endurance and not just steroids,
but things like EPO and bunch of other stuff.
You'll have more energy in a fight.
You could possibly land more blows,
possibly wind up beating someone that you wouldn't be able to beat and do damage
to them.
So it's different in a lot of ways.
Or why,
why wouldn't person take us force for him?
You know,
it's called PE,
these performance enhancing drugs.
Why wouldn't you do that in sport?
Well,
it's because they would think of it as cheating.
who does?
Well,
a lot of people don't know how many guys are cry their eyes out,
but you get caught.
Then it cried like bitches.
And they lie.
Right?
Baseball players,
they don't,
they never took drugs.
You get caught in a cry like bitches.
Right.
That's what I don't like.
Just tell him.
You know,
I'll tell you,
I'll never read the Bible,
but I see the billboards on the freeway says,
I shall not lie.
Just quit line and come out and say,
I take droids,
you know,
the NFL.
Why would you be on as far as like the NFL,
you know what drugs do is for recovery.
That's all it is.
Right?
You know,
you take,
I can give my strongest people I've ever seen,
uh,
doing,
I've seen we'd guys take more drugs than anyone I've ever had my gym.
Really?
Yeah.
Jugs don't make you strong.
You're born that way.
You're born fast.
You're born slow.
You're born with an attitude.
I know you're not well,
that's the big misconception about steroids,
right?
Is that they make you bigger.
The work makes you bigger,
is to recovery,
right.
Cause you to recover.
To do more workouts so everyone doesn't want to do workouts.
Did the people you know,
say they want to be an MMA fighter,
intimidate,
get in a cage one time?
They never get,
but Coleman told me,
mark said he had a million restaurants when he had hammer house here.
Soon as they got our bar one time,
but he never came back.
Yeah.
But there's,
there's a mile benefit to taking testosterone,
a bunch of other stuff without doing any physical work.
But almost all of it is in the fact that you could put in more work or
work and you recover far quicker than the average person.
Yeah.
But see that way if everyone took it,
you're not cheating.
You know,
you don't,
you gotta you got,
you got a corvette,
you don't have to put high test cas in.
All right.
But don't you think that like it also,
but for young guys,
he can fuck up your endocrine system and fucks up your body's production
testosterone.
So what?
So that's what hcg sport,
you got to spark donkey.
Take Ha.
Everybody takes ACG cause your nuxle streak up because if you take roids you
take tests,
you're taking more than mother nature told you so you're not shrink up.
But there are morons anyhow because you took Casey cheat your nuts wouldn't
drink up hcg.
What does that stand for?
Any trophic hormone?
It raises all your home meant vendors and sports there you cannot,
there's no sportsmanship and sports.
It mean you was to fight in front of a big crowd.
Half the crowd would want me to knock you out and the other half the crowd,
we want you to knock me out.
Does that sportsmanship?
Well that's just people.
I mean but,
but that sportsmanship is supposed to be the athletes competing without
cheating.
I mean if I,
if,
if there was a pill
that you can take that made you invulnerable,
gave you like a God pill and you took and you went into a fight and the other
guy thought he was fighting a man,
but you're,
you're invulnerable,
no one can hurt you.
You can't be hurt and you don't get tired of superhuman strength,
which show Roy still be legal or illegal point.
Well,
it would be better than steroids.
It would be like a superstar.
Roid but I mean,
wouldn't you think that that would be cheating?
No,
no,
but we'll then nobody can beat old buddy.
You just beat the fuck out of each other and nothing would ever happen to hills
right here.
It all starts up in your brain,
man.
See,
I kind of could see how you can make that argument with other sports.
But with fighting,
I mean fighting is about,
is fighting is problem solving with dire physical consequences.
I mean that's what it is.
And if you can minimize those consequences through drugs,
a lot of people would think that that would be cheating.
I look at like this,
I look at the Diaz brothers.
I'm guessing they got a lot of testosterone.
I don't know who in the hell their dad was,
but he must had a lot of tests.
Testosterone.
Well,
it's interesting.
Those guys eat Vegan and for the most part thing,
Nate eats fish and eggs too.
I don't even know if Nikki,
it's fish he might have in the past,
but I don't think he does anymore.
I think he's pretty much Vegan,
which most people that eat vegan have lower testosterone because the substrate
for developing testosterone is fats is like a cholesterol and fats and one of
the most important,
it's like when people get on ketogenic diets.
One of the more interesting things that happens when they consume a large amount
of fats and saturated fats and cholesterol is that their testosterone goes way
up.
I should wait and that you're going high cholesterol diet.
Yes.
So I don't,
I don't necessarily know if those guys have high testosterone.
What they do have is high endurance.
Their endurance is through the roof.
Right.
But a lot of that is because they participate in triathlons,
a lot of endurance running and during swimming,
biking things on those lines.
So you still have to have,
uh,
the,
the brain thought to go kick someone's ass.
Right.
But don't tell you think that Ronda Rousey has that brain thought to.
She doesn't have any testosterone.
Well,
I mean,
she has some but not a lot.
You know what I mean?
But more than other girls.
Yeah,
but not more than fine work.
Well that's a little different.
See that's the argument for steroids right there.
That's the argument because she actually has been caught,
but she's actually tested positive and then she's passing a test now,
right?
Yes.
But you know as well as I do that when a woman takes male hormones for a long
period of time,
even if they get off of them,
there's benefits that they keep forever.
Same thing with men.
Yes.
And just because you're passing the drug test,
I won't say who,
but I trained the top international shot putter.
He could golf off hand YPAR in eight days and pass a drug test.
IOC said,
I will say,
see that's it's,
it's only eight days you can get on.
Oh Nana.
Is the antivirus one of the quickest ones to get off,
right?
Yeah.
So I mean,
and I mean how I forget to take stuff for eight days.
So the benefits unquestionably a are permanent or at least some of them are.
What I think about,
you know,
what you're looking at.
You're looking at a fight career as you see it in an envelope.
And then when that day that tough fire retires,
you forget about them.
But what about the years later after a fighter's career,
if he was on antibiotics,
he would survive the fighting years and be able to continue with his older years
like me.
So what you're saying is that listening?
Well,
longevity post career.
I totally understand that.
And a lot of fighters believe that as well.
Like testosterone replacement,
growth hormone therapy for guys who have retired.
But while they're competing themselves,
they don't want to do anything because they don't want to think that the reason
why they accomplish those goals,
because they were taking drugs.
I could shoot tons of Roy's and someone's ass ain't going make them kick my ass.
It's not going to make them kick their ass.
But there's no question that some fighters fight better when they're taking
steroids.
How about just a nutritionist?
I was just cut out the nutritionist.
Yeah,
but the nutritionist look,
look,
everybody knows how to eat healthy.
I mean,
if you're eating healthy and you're training hard,
but one guy's taking steroids and one guy's not,
there's a giant advantage for the guy was taking steroids.
I just know too many people take steroids in any passenger.
I guess that's all I'm trying to say.
Right.
Well that bring up any names.
I understand and I know you're not,
but that's one of the reasons why the UFC has instituted this incredibly
invasive.
You sought a policy where they don't wake you up at six 30 in the morning.
Well l how'd you like that watch you piss in a cup.
I don't like it exactly,
but that's the only way to catch people.
Well,
I just,
I mean,
I'll never go to drug test.
I don't think the NFL,
she had drug test.
I don't think in India.
There's a good argument there,
you know?
First of all,
it's a good argument for baseball because baseball,
no one's getting hurt in the NFL.
You can make the argument that you're able to hurt guys more and then that
damages them and it shortens their career.
But,
but baseball,
there's no argument,
in my opinion,
baseball's boring as fuck.
And if,
if,
I mean some people like it,
I get it.
But what I'm saying is like if,
if you,
if you got a drug that lets you hit more balls over the fence,
take that.
That's the only thing interesting about baseballs home runs.
So how do you let that for get away with it?
You know what I'm saying?
Why not make it legal for all?
You know,
like baseball's a funny thing.
if he hit less than 50 home runs,
that gets your drug free,
but you start hitting 51 your Roy dry and seems like that's what this called.
And he talked about the base,
the steroid year.
[inaudible] we're taking a drug in 1960.
So who are they trying to kid where they,
yeah,
it's Saint Louis,
you know,
uh,
as a football team,
um,
you know,
the Raiders,
uh,
I've heard stories where I think it's a document on ESPN.
Never gone and had the ball tabs on the training table.
All right.
Well you know what I just say to the Raiders or the baseball team that the oral,
the um,
the A's,
the athletics.
What was like,
if they're in the same town,
it's like Siamese twins.
You're having sex with one girl's room section.
Both the girls.
What
if no one tested it?
New football players were taking it.
Okay.
And uh,
Oakland but why was,
why wouldn't the baseball player,
you taken it right down the street.
Clearly it probably would,
but do you think that people were thinking of steroids is being like,
uh,
like that kind of power being a crucial aspect of baseball?
I think what it was.
Sure.
But baseball is more of a skill game.
Did anyone ever from Mickey Mantle,
Roger Maris,
Hank Aaron,
do you think Hank Aaron was doing steroids course?
They had steroids back then.
Pants,
shirts 1939.
But where Pete were athletes taking them know exactly.
Yes.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Okay.
If the football team was taking it,
why wouldn't the baseball,
so we'll get these fortunate answers.
All geeks.
Anyhow,
there was a god damn thing in her life.
But there they're also a hypocritical and they got these ideas and their puppy
on air probably taking a,
you know,
um,
testosterone therapy as it is.
How's that?
Apparently one time and his doctors are big fat guy and he's talking about how
bad boy jar sub does listen to them.
And then when,
for instance,
what's a patch on here?
He's all,
that's a testosterone patch.
Huh?
What kind of thinking is that?
I mean it's very,
it's a true story.
Well there's a lot of hypocritical you when it comes to that stuff for sure.
It's just,
it's,
it's an interesting debate and a lot of people think that you should be able to
do whatever you want.
Like the pride days during the pride days,
which in my opinion,
where some of the most exciting all time mixed martial arts fights,
those guys did whatever the fuck they wanted.
And the Japanese literally told them like in their contract we will not test you
for steroids.
They told them that like,
look at horse racing.
Yeah.
Right.
Dog Racing.
Yeah.
But everybody,
that's okay.
So he just were worried about that.
Well,
equal poise right.
Echo.
Poises aqua.
It's like got a horse in the fucking title.
Yeah.
I mean,
and that's something that people take and it's a hormone for steroids.
For horses.
Exactly.
Now,
so you don't think there's anything negative.
There's obviously gotta be some drawbacks of steroids.
Right.
I went on antibiotics in 19 January,
1970 1970 1970 and uh,
so it was this 2016.
Yeah,
I'd never been off.
You never been off in 46 years.
That's insane.
It just stay on him.
That's right.
No cycle that go off
to tell everybody or off him.
Exactly.
I go out there and tell him the truth.
I don't lie to people get upset.
Are you that you're so honest about it?
I don't give a damn of the upset,
but I'm just curious and you'll never come up at the council self-respecting.
I give him hell about these geeks.
They're not doing crap.
They suck when they were kids.
They suck when you're at middle age and they suck when you're old.
That's how I look at it.
Our Damn prison.
I'll be on roids.
I'll count you bev.
Roy,
you wouldn't be putting,
our world would be in its shape.
It's in the day.
If they had some nuts,
but if they had nuts,
they wouldn't need steroids.
Right.
Cause then
let's just say some,
right.
Some aggression.
Yeah.
So my premise is a psychologist and he would test people in prisons,
a rapist hammers.
He said he had tested some,
had 25 times the rate testosterone and normal man does 25 one time.
That's why I say,
you know,
it wasn't even possible.
Well why are they out there raping people and why they killing people with no,
no remorse.
Because he got an enormous amount.
He said that he saw it.
That's why they probably did it.
He didn't,
um,
you know,
if you can't do that stuff,
he realized that.
But he thought that's why they would be on a course to do stuff like that.
It just absolutely crazy.
You take,
look at elephants,
you dug these elephants while they call,
when they,
they just ease.
I'll test house in or out,
killing each other and knock it down.
Villagers.
So the world needs more of that.
Well,
I think it needs more because of the kind of look at,
you know what?
When I was a kid,
just 10% gay.
Now they say there's 34
four 34% 4% but colleges,
I believe it too,
me,
boy bands,
there's no ways.
34% 4% oh man.
Okay,
well I'm sure someone probably want to test out your,
because look at Jeffrey Dahmer.
He's out there killing people.
Well,
he was gay too,
but I don't think,
I don't necessarily think that's a testosterone thing.
Right?
That's a sociopath psychopath thing.
Who knows?
I will say that.
Well,
I don't think,
well,
I'm not talking about the gay part,
the other part of the eating people crazy ash.
I mean,
but that's,
but that's not a good argument for testosterone if you seen that prisoners and
rapists and murderers have a lot of it,
so,
but it got a lot of opinions about Roy's,
but I've seen probably a thousand people on Roy's over the years.
Right,
okay.
Dell maybe more,
right?
That's right.
The ones who took the most drugs were not always the strongest.
I can see the strong guys didn't take that much and a lot of them.
And then the lesser guys take a ton of shit,
but he just can't do it.
Nothing.
They're just not what strong.
Well,
isn't there also a point of diminishing returns where like taking too much of it
throws your body out of balance to the point where you're not going to recover
correctly.
Cause your body's constantly dealing with this and it makes you crazy.
Right.
It can't concentrate.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a real problem that people don't want to admit.
The roid rage isn't a real thing.
I've seen it.
It's real.
It's 100% real.
I don't think there's such a thing you don't think so know.
Well you said it makes you crazy.
Yeah.
But I don't see the little,
the little guys,
you know,
there's plenty of fighters would fight a 300 pound guy cause they're just crazy,
crazy.
Right.
You know,
enrollees are fucking crazy.
Right.
But when people are taking too much steroids and it makes you crazy,
a little guy's not going to jump on a big guy and get his ass great.
You know,
because a roid rage,
he'll do it because he's,
he was born that way.
To do it.
You're more,
there's two kinds of people praying predator.
You'll find out which one you are real quick.